we can introduce market forces into the
way that governments operate to bring
them in a more competitive more open
fashion and hopefully you know creative
libertarian revolution to local level hi
I'm Ted bellacor with reason TV and
today I'll be sitting down with Matt
Harrison and Justin Hartfield of the
Prometheus Institute Harrison and
Hartfield created the do-it-yourself
democracy iPhone app and Hartfield gave
the world the weed Maps app the two are
working on a new project that uses iPad
technology to make classic libertarian
books more interactive tell me a bit
about the Prometheus Institute our
mission is to pioneer innovative
technology to advance Liberty we think
there's a need in the marketplace for
tools that help people take the great
ideas the great studies of the great
policy proposals that our movement is
putting out and have the technological
ability to put them into action and your
big thing right now is the
do-it-yourself democracy iPhone app can
you talk about that a little bit do
yourself democracy automatically locates
you in your city gives you a customized
menu of action items to do everything
from protest your taxes to start a
recall campaign protest bureaucracy
basically anything you can do to reduce
the growth of growth of government we
allow you to do how would someone in
practice use your app to beat back
government just a little bit so you're
on your way to work and there's a
construction that's taking up that lane
it's blocking or traffic making it take
an hour longer to get to work every
single day you know that the government
is causing these kind of projects that
nothing's really getting done it's kind
of a shady bid process you don't know
really who's working on the project you
want transparency so we give you action
items not only to protest bureaucracy
but to demand transparency with the bids
that are available in your city so you
can see what kind of budget your city is
putting forth what kind of taxes they're
charging you and really just giving you
the information you need to me an
advocate for liberty and to understand
what it takes to reduce government in a
practical sense so it's like basically a
high-tech way to complain to government
officials exactly right now there's a
few high-tech ways that you can ask
government for things what we'd like to
do is give people the tools to actually
reduce the growth of government to take
power back to increase competition to
increase transparency and there's
nothing really out there and the
technological platform that does that
right now so we're trying to fill that
niche one of the things that I find
interesting about
the app is that it really does zero in
on the person in whatever obscure layer
of bureaucracy is responsible for that
broken light or that pothole is that
correct I mean you if you're driving
through Chino and you see a pothole your
app knows exactly whose responsibility
that is exactly we actually had interns
research the specific departments inside
each of these small cities to find out
which email address to send the emails
to so it took hundreds of hours of
research to actually compile the data
for California because there's over 600
cities in California and there's
municipalities that run the water some
do the transportation so it took a lot
of research to do but it really works
really well when you're in a small city
because the person you're emailing you
probably know them our first-name basis
so it's kind of like an intimate
connection with your representatives and
that's what what who doesn't want an
intimate relationship local government
workers so you must come across a lot of
surprised government workers who thought
like well we actually think did you find
me right there is that there is a little
bit of resistance but we think it works
well because there's a personal
connection between you who submits the
question or submits the complaint and
the person who's receiving it so they
get your e-mail a personal phone number
the public servant has someone to
contact it's not just some amorphous
website where you know you don't know
really who's submitting the request you
actually have a person on the other end
who's demanding it and was very
aggressive in making sure that it gets
done let's shift gears a little bit talk
about another iphone app Justin you are
you gave the world weedmaps haha yes
that's what that was me thanks for those
who don't know what a jury what is it
weedmaps is a medical marijuana
dispensary locator website it's kind of
like Yelp if people are familiar with
that and it finds legal marijuana
dispensaries in California Colorado
Montana there's a couple in Nevada and
more and more states in New Jersey and
Maine being the two new estates they're
going to be adding dispensaries so it's
basically a web application and an
iphone application that lets you find
the nearest dispensary and interact with
other medical marijuana patients first
explain what happened recently in
in Los Angeles for those who don't know
and how will your app respond to that
the Los Angeles City Council recently
passed an organs ordinance that's going
to limit the number of dispensaries in
Los Angeles to essentially 70 and it's
also going to put some what I think is
unfair restrictions on the zoning of
those dispensaries and so via the DIY
democracy iPhone app you can just click
a button and it sends off an email to
your local LA City Councilmember asking
them to repeal this initiative so that's
going to be a joint venture between
weedmaps in the Prometheus Institute and
your guys next big thing with prometheus
is an interesting project that
incorporates the new iPad technology can
you talk about that a little bit we're
trying to do is go inside the book we're
going to introduce social networking
features commenting features and
interactive digital video inside the
book so that people can get to the
features they want share the features
that they want and really interact with
the ideas in a way that's really
unprecedented and what we're going to do
is we're going to start with a
libertarian classics the ones that are
out of IP protection currently all the
greats human action wrote to surf them
etc all those books that have so much
more potential in this generation but
need to be put in a medium of format
that people can identify with people can
share people can understand so then
someone cracks open the the Road to
Serfdom using your new technology what
how would it be different for the user
it's very rare that we think about the
book in its entirety so what we're going
to do is use the technology so people
can share specific bits of a book so you
can say hey Ted check out this part of
the road certain that i loved i think
you'd like this to what do you think
let's talk about that i'll send you just
to that part just to that part of the
book and let you interact with other
things that I think are similar in that
sense and taking the ideas of the book
extracting them and letting that
interact and letting the ideas and how
people react to the ideas interact in a
totally new way for either of you guys
if you look ten years into the future
what do you think how do you think the
the book will change from a user
perspective if we can harness the
digital capabilities of the new iPad
technology and similar technologies like
that I think it's going to revolutionize
the book and it's going to be more like
a movie it's going to be a immersive
experience that you take you take part
of your pushing you're interacting with
the book you're playing with concepts
you're reading with other people at the
same time you go through a book you're
seeing what other
people thought at that point in the book
it will be an experience unlike anything
else let me ask you guys a bigger
question just about Mac in general
because I know you're both Big Mac
enthusiasts if you strip away kind of
the casual hipster attire of Steve Jobs
he's he's much more kind of the evil
capitalist I guess to a lot of people
why why do progressives warm to a guy
who's really in a lot of ways much more
like Gordon Gekko than the you know Ben
& Jerry's guys or something like that
you have any idea Steve Jobs the
philanthropist news nowhere even close
to Gordon Gekko so I take umbrage to
that yeah but actually I think that's an
interesting point I think it has
something to do with the fact that Matt
kind of started as like a creative
person's computer it's always been
really good for video editing for photo
editing those are kind of more right
right brain type of kind of liberal
thinking type of jobs so it kind of
makes sense that's the artist would be
kind of into Max and artists are
typically more liberal I also look at it
as Windows going as a reaction to
Windows Windows has kind of been
perceived as the white-collar corporate
America means of Technology and so in a
sense of rebellion against that I think
a lot of progressive liberals I think
they reacted to that and want it to be
something different and so they just
picked Apple because that was not
windows not corporations but now Apple
is getting so much bigger that you see a
lot of successful entrepreneurs using
Apple products and that's I think you're
seeing a shift in that at least in the
ideology of people who are passionate
about the products as they can see that
it can make you a lot of money too and
I'd you know I love Apple as well but
you know Steve Jobs does rule with an
iron fist very famously you know he
forces people using his you know
economic power to if you want an iphone
you've got to use AT&T even if you like
Verizon and yet people just take it Oh
apples always been that way I mean we
dealt with it before we had issues with
the app store getting approval you know
the totalitarian nature of the Apple
management is pretty much legendary so
for four decades they've been stealing
people's ideas and they'll implement
them into apple software and things like
that and we just watch them do that we
still buy their products as we love them
what do you see is the next big thing in
terms of technology allowing for greater
freedom actually we've been thinking
about that a lot at Prometheus and
version 3 of the DIY democracy I
application is going to have a concept
of municipal auctions say there's a
asphalt repayment project on La Cienega
so that project will be posted out by
the government and then private bidders
can each see each post their bids and
everyone else's everyone else can see
each other's bid so it's totally
transparent when you think about what
technology is done for government or
what technology is done for business
everywhere else you have the ebays you
have the craigslist you have the
introduction of competition and choice
into all these different sectors and
it's done so well and it's
revolutionized the way people access
technology resources each other's
knowledge and everything the last
frontier there is government especially
government procurement and government
activity those are last areas where
technology hasn't introduced competition
and choice and market mechanisms
auctions all those kind of things that
we see so much in technology were there
on that last frontier and DIY democracy
is the way that we can do that we can
introduce market forces into the way
that governments operate to bring them
in a more competitive more open fashion
and hopefully you know creative
libertarian revolution to lure below
you can get